on a un Saint-Bernard là ici on a du
Terre-Neuve ici un berger allemand si
vous voulez les pâtes de gros toutou
mais ce sont des malades ces gens-là
c'est-à-dire que le les cadavres
d'animaux sont démembrées
disséqués dépossés c'est horrible et il
se les revendre comme trophées qui peut
dans sa tête être assez dérangé pour
faire ça il faut savoir que la
taxidermie on a le droit d'empailler des
animaux mais utilisez récupérer des
cadavres comme ça c'est strictement
interdit c'est honteux alors pour se
procurer ces animaux morts mots de les
récupérer chez les équarisseurs avant
que les animaux ne soient incinérés le
pire c'est que ça peut arriver à vos
animaux de compagnie sans que vous
sachiez votre animal meurt vous savez
pas s'il est incinéré voilà et en fait
ces gens-là les récupèrent alors eux
leur argument c'est dire le chien est
mort enfin ça montre quand même la
manière dont ces gens-là considèrent les
animaux c'est à dire comme des objets et
c'est c'est c'est exactement